كيف يمكن لفتاة من Beaconsfield
Iowa يقل عدد سكانها عن 20 عامًا أن
تصبح قائدة لمحطة الفضاء الدولية.
أي
اثنين آخرين من رواد الفضاء الأمريكيين ، أنا متأكد من أن هناك
شخصًا ما هناك يتتبع
[الموسيقى]
تعتقد أن أجسادنا وعقولنا
يمكن أن تتعامل بالفعل مع مهمة إلى المريخ
وهذا هو بالضبط سبب
قضاء هذا الوقت هنا لمعرفة
ما هي القيود  لذلك عندما
نستعد للذهاب إلى المريخ ، سنعلم
أننا قادرون ومستعدون ، ما هي
النصيحة التي تقدمها للفتيات الصغيرات
هناك ، ونأمل أن نذهب إلى الفضاء يومًا ما ،
أكبر نصيحة أود أن أقولها هي
عدم الاستهانة  تدفع
نفسك لتحدي نفسك للقيام بأكثر
مما تعتقد أنه يمكنك الاستمتاع به ،
سيكون انفجارًا
ستحبه في كل ثانية من
عدم الجاذبية والتحرك حسب الرغبة
هو مجرد معدل إيمان مذهل
طار جون جلين آخر مرة إلى الفضاء عندما كان
يبلغ من العمر 77 عامًا ، أي إشارة إلى ما إذا كنت
ستستمر في الطيران إلى الفضاء عندما تبلغ 77 عامًا
بيغي إذا لم أكن ميتًا
[موسيقى]